MAIN STREAM.
HE'LL BE TALKING ABOUT THAT
SHORTLY.
FIRST RANDI KAYE WHO TALKED WITH
THE PEOPLE WHO HEARD MIKE PENCE
SPEAK TODAY.
>> Reporter: WOULD YOU LIKE TO
HEAR MIKE PENCE PUSH BACK ON
DONALD TRUMP ABOUT HIS -- HIS
FALSE CLAIMS THAT PENCE HAD THE
RIGHT TO OVERTURN THE ELECTION
RESULT?
>> NO.
I'M LOOKING FORWARD TO HEARING
THE FORMER PRESIDENT SPEAK ABOUT
WHAT REAL AMERICAN LEADERSHIP
LOOKS LIKE?
>> BUT DOES THE FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT HAVE A DUTY TO PUSH
BACK AGAINST THESE FALSE CLAIMS?
>> NO, HE'S NOT.
HE'S A PRIVATE CITIZEN.
I DON'T THINK HE HAS A DUTY TO
DO THAT, NO.
>> Reporter: SHORTLY BEFORE VICE
PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE TOOK THE
STAGE AT THE FLORIDA CHAPTERS
CONFERENCE IN ORLANDO, MEMBERS
WEIGHED IN ON WHETHER PENCE
SHOULD ADDRESS THE RECENT
ATTACKS FROM HIS FORMER BOSS.
>> I DON'T KNOW THAT THIS IS THE
TIME OR PLACE FOR THAT KIND OF
CONVERSATION.
>> Reporter: THIS WEEK THE
FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP
LIED ONCE AGAIN SAYING PENCE HAD
THE AUTHORITY TO REJECT THE 2020
ELECTION RESULTS.
SO, WILL PENCE RESPOND?
>> I THINK HE'S TOO MUCH OF A
MAN WITH GREAT DEMEANOR,
CIVILITY, TO ADDRESS THAT OPENLY
IN THE PUBLIC UNTIL IT'S THE
PROPER TIME.
>> Reporter: BEFORE PENCE SPOKE,
SOME HERE DIDN'T SEE A NEED FOR
PENCE TO ADDRESS HIS DECISION TO
CERTIFY THE VOTE BECAUSE THEY
AGREE, TRUMP LOST, PERIOD.
>> JOE BIDEN WON THE ELECTION,
SO I DON'T -- YOU KNOW, I DON'T
KNOW WHAT MORE I CAN SAY.
I MEAN, JOE BIDEN WON THE
ELECTION.
THE ROLE OF THE VICE PRESIDENT
IN THAT IS VERY CEREMONIAL.
IT COUNTED THE ELECTORAL
BALLOTS.
THE MEMBERS OF CONGRESS VOTED TO
CERTIFY.
JOE BIDEN WON THE ELECTION.
>> I DON'T THINK HE NEEDS TO
ADDRESS IT.
RIGHT, WRONG, OR INDIFFERENT, WE
LOST IN 2020.
>> DO YOU NOT WANT TO HEAR PENCE
CORRECT THE RECORD THAT TRUMP IS
FALSELY CLAIMING HE COULD
OVERTURN THE ELECTION.
>> I THINK PENCE PROBABLY
FEELS -- I DON'T WANT TO SPEAK
FOR PENCE.
BUT I THINK PENCE PROBABLY FEELS
THAT THE RECORD DOES NOT NEED TO
BE CORRECTED.
OTHERWISE HE WOULD CORRECT IT.
>> THEN CAME THE FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT'S SPEECH.
>> I HEARD THIS WEEK THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID I HAD THE
RIGHT TO OVER TURN THE ELECTION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS WRONG.
I HAD NO RIGHT TO OVERTURN THE
ELECTION.
THE PRESIDENCY BELONGS TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ALONE.
>> Reporter: WE WENT BACK OUT TO
THE GROUP AFTER THE SPEECH TO
SEE HOW IT WAS RECEIVED.
>> I WAS PLEASANTLY SURPRISED AT
HOW HE HANDLED IT.
I THOUGHT HE DID A GREAT JOB.
I THINK IT'S TIME TO MOVE ON
FROM THE 2020 ELECTION AND LOOK
FORWARD TO 2024.
>> I THINK HE'S MADE IT CLEAR,
THE VICE PRESIDENT HAS, THAT HE
HAS A DIFFERENCE OF OPINION WITH
THE PRESIDENT AND THE
PRESIDENT'S TEAM OVER WHAT THE
DUTIES OF THE VICE PRESIDENT
REQUIRED ON JANUARY 6.
>> WERE YOU HAPPY TO HEAR HIM
ADDRESS IT?
>> WELL, I THINK HE NEEDED TO
ADDRESS IT.
THIS IS A GREAT AUDIENCE.
THESE ARE CONSTITUTIONAL
SCHOLARS HERE.
YOU'RE SPEAKING TO A VERY
EDUCATED GROUP.
>> I THINK MIKE PENCE DID THE
RIGHT THING.
I THINK MIKE PENCE SHOULD HAVE
DONE WHAT HE FELT WAS RIGHT, AND
IT SOUNDS LIKE HE DID WHAT HE
FELT WAS RIGHT.
>> HOW DO YOU THINK THAT COMMENT
WILL SIT WITH FORMER PRESIDENT
DONALD TRUMP BEING CALLED WRONG?
>> PROBABLY NOT WELL.
BUT I GUESS WE'LL HAVE TO WAIT
AND SEE WHAT HE SAYS.
>> FORMER VICE PRESIDENT PENCE
ALSO TALKED ABOUT HIS HOPE FOR
REPUBLICANS TO WIN THE WHITE
HOUSE IN 2024 TODAY.
DO THE PEOPLE YOU SPOKE WITH
WANT TO SEE PENCE RUN FOR
PRESIDENT?
>> ANDERSON, EVERYONE WE SPOKE
WITH SAID THEY DO THINK MIKE
PENCE SHOULD RUN FOR PRESIDENT.
REMEMBER, THIS IS FLORIDA, AND
THIS WAS THE FLORIDA CHAPTER OF
THE FEDERALIST SOCIETY.
SO, OF COURSE A LOT OF PEOPLE
THERE ALSO SAYING THEY WOULD
LIKE TO SEE FLORIDA GOVERNOR RON
DeSANTIS JUMP INTO THE RACE FOR
THE WHITE HOUSE AS WELL.
REGARDING PENCE, EVERYONE THERE
SAID THEY WERE VERY HAPPY TO SEE
HIM STANDING UP TO DONALD TRUMP.
THEY DO THINK THAT THE TWO MEN
WILL FIGURE OUT THEIR
DIFFERENCES AT SOME POINT AND
PUT ON A UNITED FRONT FOR THE
PARTY, WHICH FOLKS TOLD US IS
VERY IMPORTANT, OF COURSE.
BUT WHAT'S KEY HERE IS THAT EVEN
IF DONALD TRUMP MAKES A PLAY FOR
THE WHITE HOUSE AGAIN, MOST
EVERYONE WE SPOKE WITH SAID THAT
THAT SHOULD NOT HOLD MIKE PENCE
BACK.
THEY THINK HE SHOULD STILL JUMP
INTO THE RACE, ANDERSON.
>> APPRECIATE IT.
I WANT TO PLAY WHAT FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT PENCE SAID TODAY
AGAIN.
LISTEN, FOR THE VIEWERS.
>> JANUARY 6 WAS A DARK DAY IN
THE HISTORY OF THE UNITED STATES
CAPITOL.
LIVES WERE LOST AND MANY WERE
INJURED.
BUT THANKS TO THE COURAGEOUS
ACTION OF THE CAPITOL POLICE AND
FEDERAL LAW ENFORCEMENT, THE
VIOLENCE WAS QUELLED, THE
CAPITOL WAS SECURE, AND WE
RECONVENED THE CONGRESS THAT
VERY SAME DAY TO FINISH OUR WORK
UNDER THE CONSTITUTION OF THE
UNITED STATES AND THE LAWS OF
THIS COUNTRY.
>> WHAT DO YOU MAKE, PAUL, OF
WHAT PENCE SAID AND THE
RESPONSE?
>> WELL, IT'S -- THE FEDERALIST
SOCIETY CLAIMS TO BE COMMITTED
TO -- THESE ARE THEIR WORDS.
I LOOKED UP THEIR WEBSITE.
THE PRINCIPLES OF LIMITED
GOVERNMENT EMBODIED IN OUR
CONSTITUTION.
WELL, THE CONSTITUTION'S
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR, THE WOMAN
RANDI INTERVIEWED IS RIGHT, THE
VICE PRESIDENT IS ONLY
CEREMONIAL.
THERE'S NOT ANY QUESTION.
IT'S AS IF NEIL DEGRASSE TYSON
WERE SPEAKING TO A GROUP OF
ASTROPHYSICISTS AND SAID DONALD
TRUMP IS WRONG.
THE MOON IS NOT MADE OF GREEN
CHEESE.
IT'S MADE OF ROCK.
AND THEY SAID, I'M NOT SURE.
IT'S PREPOSTEROUS.
I'M SURE RANDI FOUND SOME
PRINCIPLED CONSTITUTIONALIST
THERE.
THEY CLAIM TO ALL BE.
I WAS DISAPPOINTED FRANKLY THEY
DIDN'T CARRY HIM AROUND ON THEIR
SHOULDERS FOR SAVING THE
CONSTITUTION BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT
THAT WHOLE GROUP CLAIMS TO BE
ABOUT.
I'M BEGINNING TO WONDER IF THEY
REALLY ARE.
>> DO YOU THINK THE FORMER VICE
PRESIDENT MADE THE RIGHT CALL,
PUBLICLY REBUKING THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, JUST SAYING HE WAS
WRONG?
DID HE HAVE A CHOICE?
>> I DO ACTUALLY.
HIS SPEECH WAS TERRIFIC.
HIS WORDS WERE TERRIFIC.
HIS ACTIONS ON JANUARY 6 WERE
RIGHT ON AND IN ACCORDANCE WITH
THE LAW OF AMERICA AND WHAT
HAPPENED ON ELECTION DAY.
HE'S PLAYED THIS CORRECTLY I
THINK ALL THE WAY THROUGH.
AS A POLITICAL MATTER, THIS IS
THE CAMPAIGN MIKE PENCE IS GOING
TO HAVE TO RUN.
HE'S OBVIOUSLY RUNNING.
DONALD TRUMP I THINK IS
OBVIOUSLY RUNNING.
AND MIKE PENCE AND DONALD TRUMP
ARE GOING TO HAVE A GREAT DEBATE
ABOUT WHETHER THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY IS GOING TO SEE IT THE WAY
DONALD TRUMP DID OR THE WAY MIKE
PENCE DID.
AND SO I WOULD LOOK AT THIS
SPEECH TODAY FRANKLY AS
SOMETHING OF A KICKOFF OF THAT
DEBATE.
I ASSUME TRUMP WILL HAVE
SOMETHING TO SAY WHEN HE FINALLY
HEARS THE PENCE CLIP.
BUT THIS IS WHAT HE AND I ASSUME
GOVERNOR CHRIS CHRISTIE, WHO
LOOKS LIKE HE IS RUNNING AS
WELL, ARE GOING TO ARGUE.
IT'S ESSENTIALLY THIS, I STOOD
BY DONALD TRUMP EVERY STEP OF
THE WAY, BUT COME JANUARY 6 WE
HAD TO PART WAYS BECAUSE THE
CONSTITUTION MANDATED IT.
AND THAT'S WHERE WE ARE AS A
PARTY.
I THOUGHT PENCE WAS GREAT TODAY
AND I'M GLAD HE GAVE THE SPEECH
HE DID.
>> WE'VE SEEN THIS BACK AND
FORTH BETWEEN TRUMP AND PENCE
THIS WEEK.
THE BALL I GUESS IS IN TRUMP'S
COURT, IF YOU WANT TO USE THAT
ANALOGY.
DOES PENCE -- I MEAN, IN THIS
REPUBLICAN PARTY, DO YOU THINK
PENCE HAS A SHOT?
>> LOOK, I DEFER TO SCOTT.
HE KNOWS THIS PARTY FAR BETTER
THAN I DO.
I WOULD NOTE THAT A YEAR AGO,
THREE OR FOUR WEEKS AFTER THE
INSURRECTION OF MIKE PENCE WHO I
DON'T AGREE WITH POLITICALLY,
BUT I KNOW HIM.
I'VE KNOWN HIM A LONG TIME.
HE HAS PROFOUND AND DEEP AND
CHRISTIAN FAITH AND HE WENT TO A
CHRISTIAN CONSERVATIVE GROUP
CALLED FAITH FREEDOM COALITION,
AND HE WAS BOOED.
AND ONE GUY YELLED OUT, TRAITOR.
NOW, IF THE CHRISTIANS PREFER
DONALD TRUMP, WHO CAN'T NAME A
SINGLE BOOK IN THE BIBLE, TO
MIKE PENCE, I THINK THAT TELLS
YOU SOMETHING.
IF THE CONSTITUTIONALISTS ARE AT
BEST VERY LUKEWARM AND KIND OF
SILENT IN SUPPORTING THE GUY WHO
HELPED SAVE THE CONSTITUTION AND
INSTEAD FOR THE
INSURRECTIONIST -- IN OTHER
WORDS, I THINK IT LOOKS LIKE A
ROUT.
I THINK THE PEOPLE WHO SHOULD BE
MOST COMMITTED TO MIKE PENCE,
SEEM TO NOT BE BACKING HIM AT
ALL, THINK DONALD TRUMP HAS SO
PERVERTED AND POLLUTED THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY IT MAY BE
BEYOND SALVATION.
>> SCOTT, I WONDER WHAT YOU MADE
OF THE RNC RESOLUTION CENSURING
CONGRESSMAN KINZING GER AND
CONGRESSWOMAN CHENEY, CLAIMING
THE JANUARY 6 COMMITTEE IS GOING
AFTER ORDINARY AMERICANS WHO ARE
ENGAGED IN LEGITIMATE POLITICAL
DISCOURSE.
>> HERE WE ARE SITTING IN THE
GREATEST POLITICAL ENVIRONMENT
OF MY ADULTHOOD FOR REPUBLICANS
IN TERMS OF TRYING TO TAKE BACK
THE HOUSE AND THE SENATE IN
NOVEMBER.
AND REALLY I THINK HEADING
TOWARDS 2024.
AND WE HAVE ALL THESE ISSUES AND
ALL THESE AMAZING THINGS TO TALK
ABOUT.
AND AT THE RNC, WHICH I'VE BEEN
A DELEGATE TO THE LAST SEVERAL
CONVENTIONS.
I'M A PROUD REPUBLICAN AND WILL
BE VOTING REPUBLICAN IN THE
FUTURE AND HAVE IN MY LIFE.
HERE WE ARE TODAY CHANGING THE
CONVERSATION.
LET'S RE-LITIGATE JANUARY 6th.
LET'S TELL PEOPLE THEY DIDN'T
REALLY SEE WHAT THEY SAW ON TV.
LET'S RELITIGATE THE 2020
ELECTION.
THIS IS A RECIPE FOR FAILURE.
WE HAVE ALL OF THIS ENVIRONMENT,
ALL OF THESE ISSUES, ALL OF THIS
FORWARD LOOKING WE COULD BE
DOING.
BY THE WAY, THIS IS A PARTY THAT
COULD NOT BE BOTHERED TO WRITE A
PLATFORM IN 2020.
AND NOW WE'VE SPENT MORE TIME
WRITING THIS RESOLUTION THAN WE
SPENT ON WRITING A POLICY
PLATFORM IN THE LAST
PRESIDENTIAL ELECTION.
IT IS NOT LEGITIMATE.
>> SCOTT, WHEN YOU SAY IT LIKE
THAT --
>> TO CRASH INTO THE CAPITOL --
IT SOUNDS RIDICULOUS BECAUSE IT
IS RIDICULOUS.
YOU CANNOT CRASH THE CAPITOL,
DEFILE THE HOUSE AND THE SENATE,
AND ATTACK THE POLICE.
THAT'S NOT LEGITIMATE.
I KNOW CHAIRWOMAN McDANIEL PUT
OUT A STATEMENT SAYING THERE'S A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN THE PEOPLE
PROTESTING VERSUS THE RIOTERS AT
THE CAPITOL.
THAT'S NOT WHAT THE RESOLUTION
SAYS, AND IF THAT'S WHAT THEY
MEANT, THAT'S WHAT THEY SHOULD
HAVE PUT IN THERE.
THIS IS AN UNFORCED ERROR THAT
HURTS THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IN
ITS ATTEMPT TO